in an earthquake having the latest
information could be key to survival
Wednesday the US Geological Survey
mistakenly sent alerts for an earthquake
that happened in 1925 now that quake
wrecked Santa Barbara and caused
millions of dollars of damage Carter
Evans is at the quake cottage in Burbank
California with how scientists are
working to warn people before
earthquakes hit Carter good morning good
morning this is a state-of-the-art
earthquake simulator and the beauty of
it is we know exactly when the shaking
is going to start but what if you got a
warning before the real thing well that
does actually exist it's called shake
alert it was set to roll out next year
but now budget cuts could put all of
that in jeopardy
in an earthquake zone every second
counts early warning systems are already
operational in Mexico and Japan prior to
a massive 9.0 quake in 2011 people in
Tokyo got a quake warning of more than
60 seconds
now the Los Angeles rail system is
literally on track with its own early
warning program all train operators are
to stop your train at the next station
and hold when an alert sounds during
this simulation at the rail Operations
Center supervisors immediately bring all
83 trains in the system to a stop and
then take cover themselves in a
real-world scenario this all would have
happened before the shaking began Josh
bashyam is founder of early warning labs
one of just a few companies approved by
the US government to send out advanced
earthquake alerts today they got a 30
second warning that doesn't seem like
much time it doesn't it doesn't right
but it takes about 12 seconds to stop a
commuter train or about 10 seconds to
take an elevator to the closest floor or
even just three seconds to get
underneath the desk you can save a lot
of lives during an earthquake seismic
waves radiate from the epicenter like
waves on a pond currently more than 700
sensors most of them in Southern
California detect those waves passing
along data they can be used to predict
when shaking will start in nearby cities
ok we now have 41 seconds before the
shaking is expected to come in here to
Pasadena seismologist Lucy Jones helped
develop the early warning system for the
US Geological Survey it still needs
nearly a thousand more seismic sensors
across the West but that plan is now in
jeopardy if the President's budget is
passed by Congress the program will be
stopped because this is one of the
things being eliminated
Jones and others hope it doesn't take a
disaster to convince lawmakers to keep
the program alive Japan started their
program after 5,000 people died in Kobe
Mexico started their program after
10,000 people died in Mexico City we are
trying to be the first country to do it
without killing the people first
now if the budget is cut that means
large parts of Northern California organ
in Washington where the sensors still
need to be installed will not get an
early warning the ultimate goal David is
to make sure that warning gets out to
everyone's cell phone before the quake
hits Clara thanks so much